when you impact this idea of human
intellect you'll find that what's
highest in us namely our capacity for
thought survives the death of the body
[Music]
so we are here on today's Sunday special
with Edward fazer he's the author of a
book called 5 proofs of the existence of
gods we're gonna make him prove god to
us in just a second but first let's talk
about your public Wi-Fi whether you're
in a cafe or a hotel we often rely on
public Wi-Fi to use the internet on the
go but something as simple as paying
your bills online from a Starbucks can
leave your data exposed a hacker can
easily intercept your information
stealing passwords credit card numbers
personal details it's not just hackers
either they're government agencies like
the NSA that monitored the entire
Internet
you never know what's happening with
that information so what can you do to
defend yourself well the software I use
to protect my online activity from spies
and data thieves is expressvpn
expressvpn has easy to use apps they
were unseemly in the background of my
computer phone and tablet expressvpn
secures and anonymizes your internet
browsing by encrypting your data and
hiding your public IP address using
expressvpn I can safely surf on public
Wi-Fi without being snooped on having my
personal data stolen for the best
protection I recommend using expressvpn
every single time you go online and it's
pretty inexpensive it just cost about
seven bucks a month and comes with a
30-day money-back guarantee so you have
nothing to lose to take back your
internet privacy today and find out how
you can get three months for free go to
expressvpn comm slash Ben that's expr
ESS VPN comm slash been for three months
free with that 1-year package get
expressvpn and secure your internet now
alright so we are here as I say with
Edward fazer
and this is his book five proofs of the
existence of God it's not his only book
he's written a bevy of them professor
Fraser thanks so much for stopping by I
really appreciate here so let's talk a
little bit about what brought you to
this point in your life because your
story is not quite you grew up a
religious person and then just start
writing about religion that's that's
kind of my story but you came at this
from a very different perspective
writing about Aristotle and Aquinas how
did you get from where you work as an
atheist you're the player you're writing
about religion for a living basically
yeah well I you know I was brought up
Catholic and I fell away from the church
when I was a teenager and by the time I
got early to my college years I became
an atheist I was an atheist for about
ten years roughly the decade of the
1990s and during the last part
of my decade as an atheist I was a
graduate student I was given courses to
teach while a grad student introduction
to philosophy courses I got a chance to
teach a philosophy religion course and
so you want to teach students material
that they're gonna be interested in
especially since a lot of these kids
will never take another philosophy
course so you don't want to focus on
topics that are too technical and
abstract you want to focus on topics
that anybody would be interested in
whether or not they're interested in
philosophy so I thought well looking at
the arguments for God's existence would
be a good topic to go with so I did that
but it got boring teaching them the way
that they're so often Todd which is
basically lying the arguments up and you
trot out some of the stock objections
and then conclude that the arguments are
really kind of silly in Lane why would
anybody believe this let's move on to
something else it was boring so I
thought well I I wanted to make it
interesting to the students make it
understandable to them why anybody would
ever have believed these arguments in
the first place and turned into a real
philosophical debate so that got me that
was one of several things that got me to
revisit the arguments and to and to go
back into the literature and to read
what Aquinas had actually said and what
Leibniz had actually said and what
Aristotle had actually said and what
their contemporary defenders were saying
so that I could understand the arguments
better as a way of presenting them in
the classroom so he had a real horse
race there even though I ended up always
out ended up you know at the end of the
of this section concluding the arguments
didn't work at least I could make it a
real debate as time went on I got deeper
into the arguments I started to see
gradually that well first of all a lot
of the objections that were trotted out
I realized were aimed at caricatures
they were aimed at straw men they
weren't really attacking what Aquinas or
liveness or whoever had actually said so
that well that's interesting right and
graduate went from that to thinking well
actually so these arguments aren't as
bad as they are usually presented as
being and as I always I always taken
them to be I went from that to thinking
as time went on this took this occurred
over the course of a few years during
the late 90s to thinking well actually
these arguments are kind of interesting
philosophically interesting they raised
some interesting puzzles and offer some
answers gradually that morphed in turn
into the idea that you know these
arguments are actually kind of
challenging they're very serious
arguments and eventually I concluded you
know what these arguments were right all
along and I had been wrong and that took
several years for that to happen but it
was basically in the course of teach
other people the arguments and trying to
get them to understand them and what you
know when I when I went through my
education as a philosopher in graduate
school we were always taught something
that philosophy departments hammer-on I
think it's a very good lesson always try
to see what could be said for an idea
even though you might disagree with it
try to get yourself into the mind of
someone who thinks different than you do
and doing that actually led me to change
my mind on this particular topic so what
led you to atheism in the first place
what was it that made you drop away from
the church basically it's it's it's a
common story where you start to study
philosophy and especially if you're
coming at it from a religious point of
view or at least a point of view that
takes the existence of God and other
religious ideas for granted and then you
encounter skeptical writers like
Nietzsche or David Hume or Bertrand
Russell or someone like that you're very
impressed by that because you hadn't
heard it before you didn't realize there
were people who are presenting these
objections so you're very impressed by
it you're usually a teenager anyway so
you're open to hearing the language of
rebellion you're open to hearing the
idea that what your parents taught you
in with society takes for granted is all
wrong
so I would say that was part of the
attraction that I was hearing that stuff
for the first time it was exciting it
was different I was drawn to it for that
reason it also happened to be a very
prominent attitude very prevalent
attitude in academic philosophy today
that the traditional arguments are no
good so you kind of go along with that
as well academic philosophers are not
always as independent as they'd like to
think they are as far as critical
thinking is concerned they often are
quite willing to go along with whatever
the consensus of the profession might
happen to be so your book has five
proofs of the existence of God and I
want to go through some of them with you
because I think that you know like as
you say most people when they think
about God they think about you know
whatever their parents told them about
when they were kids and they haven't
really taken a serious look at okay why
would people think God exists other than
my parents think God exists and I like
beautiful sunsets so what is the actual
philosophical grounding for the idea
that there might in fact be a God so
which of these proofs is your favorite
and if you could explicate it for us
that'd be that'd be great yeah probably
my favorite is the first one in the book
which I labeled the Aristotelian proof
and as you can guess from that label
that goes back to Aristotle and it is
important to emphasize as I do in the
book none of these arguments I put for
in the book are new they're not original
with me the formulations I give the way
I present them might be
might be novel but the basic idea the
basic nerve of each proof goes back in
in most cases centuries even millennia
case of Aristotle's argument at least
2300 years if not more cos you even see
an earlier version of that in Plato so
if you want me to present you know a
simplified version the argument so
basically the Aristotelian argument
starts from the fact that change occurs
right so you know the the water in the
cup here started out being really cold
and it came from the fridge and now it's
kind of lukewarm right that would be an
example of change or I move my hand
through space and so for that's an
example of change Aristotle argues that
on analysis change always involves the
actualization of a potential something
going from potential to actual my hands
potentially over there now it's actually
over there waters potentially lukewarm
then it becomes actually lukewarm and he
develops this idea in response to a
couple ancient Greek philosophers named
Parmenides and Zeno who deny that change
was possible so he presents this
argument of what change is as a way to
answer them but it also forms the
starting point of his argument for for
God for what he calls an unmoved mover
the prime unmoved mover of the world
because the idea is that well if change
involves going for potential to actual
we have to ask how does that ever happen
and his answer is that something can go
from potential to actual only if there's
already something there that's actual
that makes that happen so to make that a
little more concrete my hands actually
right here it's potentially to the left
right and for that for actually to
become to the left right there has to be
something already actual that makes that
happen the firing of the nerves in my
nervous system that causes the muscles
to flex so Aristotle proceeds to the
conclusion that well whenever something
goes for potential to actual there's
always something already actual that
makes that happen and if that already
actual thing goes for potential to
actual there's something already actual
making that happen so we've got one
thing being changed by another being
changed by another or one thing being
actualized by another being actualized
by another and so forth and crucial step
in this argument the most fundamental
way in which this is true for Aristotle
has to do with series of changers or
causes that extend not backward in time
into the past but downward here and now
you might say so my hand moves here and
now because the motor neurons are firing
here and now and those motor neurons are
firing here and now because they're
other neurons firing here and now and
that's only possible because my nervous
system is held
place you might say by its molecular
structure and so forth so we have one
level of reality here and now actualized
by another actualize by another and
Aristotle concludes that we would have a
vicious regress if there weren't
something at the bottom level you might
say that actualizes everything else
without having to be actualized because
it's already as he puts it purely actual
it's moving other things or changing
other things without itself being moved
or changed it's a what I call in the
book a purely actual actual Iser or an
unchanging changer or an unmoving mover
and if there weren't such a thing
operating here and now not not just
something that knocks down the first
domino back at the Big Bang but here and
now then there wouldn't be changed going
on here and now that's the basic idea of
the argument okay and what makes that
thing God per se right what can it just
be a thing well what else it all the
things that we think of that right as
well the next stage of the argument you
see an Aristotle and in later
Aristotelian like Thomas Aquinas
is to start unpacking what something
would have to be like in order to fit
this description of being an unmoved
mover a purely actual actualize er to
use my more technical language and one
of the things they say is well look I
mean if change involves going from
potential to actual and this cause of
things is purely actual it's got no
potential it's already as it were fully
actual then it can't be capable of
change it's not susceptible of change
it's an unchanging changer but if it's
unchanging then it must be outside of
time in space because things that are in
time and space are susceptible of change
they're capable of changing so if it's
not capable of changing it must be
outside of time and space material
things physical things are also always
changeable in theory they're always made
up of parts for example that can be
rearranged so if it's not changeable it
must not be a material thing either
furthermore anytime we see any sort of
power you might say manifest in the
world like the way I have the power to
pick this cup up or the way that an
earthquake has the power to knock a bowl
door down a hill or what have you that
always involves the actualization of a
potential so if we work back to
something that actualizes every
potential about being actualized that
means it's the source of the exercise of
every power that exists in the worlds
the source of all power activity which
case it must be all-powerful so we get
attributes divine attributes or
characteristics like being outside time
in space
being immaterial being all-powerful and
so forth and you go down the list some
of them the reasoning is a little more
complicated but you can argue that in
God there must be something like
intellect or thought something like will
or choice so you get the whole battery
of divine attributes that characterize
God has traditionally conceived in both
philosophy and in the monotheistic
religions so that there are two
objections that I've seen leverage
particularly at this argument one
objection is why couldn't there just be
a vicious regress well what's the
problem with efficient regress okay so
it just keeps going back and back and
back and back and there's no actual
unmoved mover it's just a series of
things that are contingent on one
another why couldn't that actually be a
possibility yeah well if you posit that
if you if you suppose that there's no
beginning to the series that there's no
bottom level that better way to put it
in my view um then you don't really have
an explanation of what you started out
with you just keep deferring the
explanation it's like an endless series
of IOUs that's never backed by actual
money the idea being that if there
weren't something that could actualize
everything else or move everything else
without itself being moved then you
wouldn't have the the the motion or
change that you started out trying to
explain the movement of the hand or the
water grown lukewarm or whatever it
might be and this is this is this idea
that why don't we just postulate that
there's no explanation at all is
something we would never consider in any
other context in chemistry class you
know if there's some explosion because
you mix two chemicals together that
professor told you just not to goof
around he wouldn't take seriously for a
moment if he said what who did that if
you said well there's no explanation
just happen right nobody would take that
seriously in the context of science in
the context of everyday life the only
place where people start trying to take
seriously or pretend to take seriously
the idea that there aren't really any
explanations is when they're confronted
with an argument for God's existence and
suddenly they say there's well maybe we
just throw up our hands and say there is
no explanation but there's cognitive
dissonance there because they wouldn't
say that in any other context they
couldn't coherently say that in any
other context if you push forward
consistently that basic idea the things
must have explanations you're gonna be
led unavoidably to the existence of an
unmoved mover or on cause cause and that
argument you're making about the
sufficiency of reason actually is a
separate argument that you have in the
book you can make it a separate argument
as I do in the book right there the kind
of principle of sufficient reason as you
mentioned this Leibniz argument
I guess yeah essentially if there's a
reason for everything then there has to
be kind of a core reason yeah is that is
that that's a pretty weak way of putting
it but that's sort of these the essence
of the argument yeah so live missus
argument and I label it in the book the
rationalist argument because liveness is
one of the best-known philosophers
classified as a rationalist in history
of philosophy but he's not the only one
who presents this sort of argument it it
argues for God's existence in a way that
avoids the kind of reasoning about the
nature of cause-and-effect or reason
about the nature of physical object or
any of these other starting points that
some of the other arguments begin with
it just starts with the idea of
explanation it starts with what is
called the principle of sufficient
reason the idea that for anything that
exists any fact about it any event that
occurs there must be some reason
sufficient or adequate to explain why it
exists why it occurred in just the way
it did rather than some other way and so
forth now Leibniz would argue that this
is a bedrock principle of human
rationality
it's presupposed in all scientific
inquiry it's presuppose in all
philosophical investigations including
atheistic ones and as I argue in the
book if you try to deny it you're
ultimately led into incoherence so it's
really no coherent way to deny it
whether you're an atheist or or a theist
okay but if you take that starting point
seriously the idea that things have
explanations they're intelligible they
can be made sense of then you're
unavoidably going to be led live it's
argues to the existence of God
understood as a necessary being and so
he moves to this distinction between
what he calls a necessary versus a
contingent thing a contingent thing is
something that it exists but it didn't
have to it could have been different
so we exist but had my parents never met
I wouldn't be here had your parents
never met you wouldn't be here and so
forth this situation this interview
exists but had you never invited me I
wouldn't wouldn't have occurred and so
forth so all these things are contingent
upon other things and as long as we're
locked in the realm of contingent things
things that could have been otherwise
Leibniz argues we don't have an ultimate
explanation
the ultimate explanation of why anything
exists at all why for example this
universe exists at all rather than some
alternative possible universe or any
universe at all is if there's something
that caused it that itself could not
have been otherwise something that
exists in a necessary rather than
engine way if something in its nature
where not only does it exist but it
could not have not existed if you don't
have that you don't have an ultimate
explanation for anything that's the
rationalist proof or the argument from
the principle of sufficient reason so in
a second I'm gonna ask you sort of the
flip side of the argument ask about an
infinite regress aside from talking
about all this uplifting stuff let's
talk about your death okay so life
insurance is pretty important it's also
really confusing which is why four out
of ten people probably don't have it
maybe you're one of those folks but if
anything were to happen to you it's
important your loved ones be taken care
of because aside from you plotting
they're gonna be real sad if they can't
pay for the coffin life insurance rates
are the lowest they've been in twenty
years the best time to buy is now the
best place to buy is policy genius calm
policy genius is the easy way to compare
life insurance online in just five
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers to find the best policy for
you and when you compare those quotes
you save money it is indeed that simple
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance they've placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage and
they don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renter's insurance and health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so if you've been putting off
getting life insurance no reason to put
it off any longer go to policy genius
com get quotes apply in minutes it is
indeed that easy you should go do it
right now while you're listening and do
it right now because rates are the
lowest in 20 years policy genius calm
it is indeed the easy way to compare and
buy life insurance go check it out right
now policy genius.com again there are
millions of people who are using it
everybody is checking it out comparing
rates and there is no reason why any
rational person any sentient human being
would be without life insurance
particularly if you have a family at a
time of rising costs go check it out
right now
that's policy genius.com to compare and
buy life insurance ok so back to the
question so the the sort of flip side of
the infinite regress question is I guess
the Bertrand Russell question which is
why don't we just hit a certain
bare-root fact ok fine
there may not be an explanation for
something but this is just the way that
it is why do we always need an
explanation for everything why can't it
be that there's rationality to a certain
point and then beyond that that's it
there's no place to go yeah so yeah you
mentioned Russell as a someone who
suggests this response another one is a
guy named Jo Mackey was another
prominent academic atheist and their
idea is that well the Atheist can simply
take the view that we have explanations
for things down to the level of the
fundamental laws
physics whatever they turn out to be the
fundamental laws of nature but then we
reach that level where it's worth the
level of what you refer to as brute
facts where a brute fact is one that not
only is at the bottom level of
explanation but it itself has no
explanation at all not just it's
important know what they mean by this
they don't just mean something that has
an explanation but we don't know it
we're not smart enough to figure it out
know what they have in mind is the idea
of something that has no explanation it
has no intelligibility you cannot make
sense of it even the most brilliant mind
in principle even God's mind if God
existed and they think God doesn't exist
couldn't make sense of it cuz there's no
sense to be made that's the idea of a
brute fact not just something that we
don't know the explanation of but it has
no explanation or intelligibility no
rhyme or reason whatsoever now I argue
that that idea is ultimately incoherent
that you can't really make sense of the
idea that we can explain what's going on
in the world of our experience by
reference to certain laws of nature laws
of chemistry and physics and then you
can splain those laws in terms of deeper
laws of physics and those in terms of
yet deeper laws but when you get to the
deepest level of laws you have an
unintelligible brute facts I mean that
there is no rhyme or reason to that I
would argue is like being a little
pregnant it's that you know you either
have explanations all the way down or
you don't there's no middle ground and I
compare it to you know putting your
books on a shelf because you don't want
them to fall put them neatly on a shelf
then you take the shelf what's gonna
support this and you put them on two
brackets right okay then you said what's
gonna support the brackets and you put
the brackets on these two rods right and
then you take finally those two rods and
instead of fastening them to the wall
you just let go with them right they're
gonna take everything down with it right
the fact that the books are supported by
the the shelf and the shelf by the
brackets and the brackets by the rods
none of that support is going to exist
at all unless there's something you can
fasten them to which holds all of that
stuff up without itself being held up if
there's nothing like that then the books
will fall to the ground the support that
the books get you might say is borrowed
from the support of the shelf which
borrows it in turn from the brackets and
so forth and the same way I would say
that we explain what happens in the
world of our experience by reference to
certain laws of chemistry and physics
and those laws in terms of deeper laws
at each level you're in a situation
it's like the books on the shelf to
support the lower level the lower levels
give the higher levels is itself
borrowed support and unless there's
something to borrow it from some bottom
level of reality that can make
everything else intelligible but it
doesn't need anything else to cause it
it's it's got its intelligibility or
explanation built into it then you've
got nothing for everything else in the
chain to borrow support from the whole
system's gonna call it seems like
they're taking all the attributes if
there is a logic to the universe that we
can understand at least to a certain
point but not beyond that and they're
just not calling it God well that right
so so that's a very good point because
someone could hear that the point I've
just made and in response would say okay
fair enough
we can't say coherently that the bottom
level of laws has no explanation is just
a brute fact so why don't we say that
that is the necessary being maybe the
fundamental laws of nature themselves
exists in an absolutely necessary way
they couldn't be otherwise so now we've
gotten a complete explanation of
everything it exists but it's an
atheistic explanation because it's not
God okay that's kind of the response
that you're that you're throwing out
there what I would say to that is well
once you it'd not acknowledge that
there's something that exists in an
absolutely necessary way it's not
contingent on anything else it's self
explanatory then you need to ask well
what follows from that one of the things
you're gonna have to say about it for
example is that if it exists in an
absolutely necessary way then it must be
what I referred to earlier as a purely
actual entity something with no
potentiality well wait a sec we already
noted earlier what follows from that
it's gonna be something that's outside
of time and space something that's not
material something that's all-powerful
so on analysis this so-called atheist
ultimate explanation is itself going to
turn out to have the divine attributes
it's gonna turn out to be God
you really can't escape it and it only
seems like you're getting to something
other than God because you haven't
really thought through the implications
of what it is for something to be to
exist in an absolutely necessary way and
this is why when I was reading your
books and I stumbled on the the line
that Aquinas says and it's this thing
that we call God it occurred to him for
the first time that as a religious
person you're taught that God is sort of
the starting points of the argument not
the end point of the argument you're
taught that everything you're taught
that God exists and then everything else
comes from that and the way that you're
arguing is basically there is
this thing that needs to exist it does
exist and it's and we're calling that
thing God so it's really not you're
arguing from God's existence to
everything else you're sort of arguing
from everything else back to God's
existence right which is it which is a
more logical way of going about it so
with all of the said if these arguments
are plausible why do you think it is
that they're increasingly unpopular
levels of religious activity are going
down in the West levels of religious
belief are going down in the West is it
just that people have never dealt with
these arguments or they decide that
they're not interested in hearing the
arguments because it's more fun to be a
theist than not to be a theist why is
atheism gaining is it it's a little bit
of both I would say speaking for the
perspective of an academic philosopher a
major part of the problem is the hyper
specialization of modern academic life
we just know so much about so many
different things you could spend your
whole life for example just doing
molecular biology and never read
anything any other discipline and you
still will not have plumb the depths of
that little that one field well it's not
a little field but that one field
molecular biology right that's true even
in philosophy itself and in different
academic disciplines they've all got
their sub disciplines and you could
spend your whole life just studying the
sub disciplines now what follows from
that is that you have fewer and fewer
generalists in modern academic life in
other words people who try to look at
the big picture if you talk about an
Aristotle or to go back you know far
fewer centuries a Descartes
we're gonna go back a hundred years 150
years the average philosophers
scientists in those days for most of the
history of Western thought up until
about a century or so ago could
literally be a know-it-all
you could still master all the different
bodies of knowledge and you can know a
lot about philosophy and a lot about
physics a lot about biology and all the
rest much harder to do that now so part
of the problem is that you get people
outside of philosophy but also even
people within philosophy who simply
don't know a whole lot about the kind of
arguments that I talked about in the
book they may know nothing more than
whatever cliches were trotted out in
their introduction to philosophy class
when they were a freshman or a soft
sophomore and they heard some of the
canned objections that were aimed at
caricatures of Aquinas or Aristotle and
Leibniz and then they never looked back
they and then they repeated their own
students when they teach an introduction
to philosophy class say so part of the
problem is just that it's lack of
knowledge on the part of your average
intellectual or your
academic because modern intellectual
life has become so specialized and
fragmented it's hard to know enough
about the issue
unfortunately ego prevents people from
refraining from talking about things
they don't know about so you'll have
someone like a Richard Dawkins for
example who's undeniably a brilliant man
a very good writer and so forth he knows
a lot about biology
unfortunately he knows very little about
philosophy and even less about theology
but for some reason that doesn't keep
him from pontificating on those subjects
right so he trots out the stock
objections that he might have heard when
he was an undergraduate and he doesn't
bother to sort of do the research and so
forth and so what happens is when
someone with that degree of prominence
repeats the same tiresome and tired
objections then that gives them new life
because people think will Richard
Dawkins he's a smart guy's an Oxford
professor he must know what he's talking
about not necessarily but that gives a
whole other generation of young people
students and so forth the same erroneous
ideas about the arguments and so they
get perpetuated that way that's another
part of the part of the reason and one
of the things about reading your books
and talking about actual philosophic
arguments for the existence of God is
that after you read your books and then
you go and you read somebody like
Dawkins and he's talking about flying
spaghetti monster he realizes either
he's either deliberately missing the
point or he's completely dissing the
point non deliberate right to be
charitable then yeah oh yeah that his
argument doesn't actually correlate to
anything that any religious person has
ever seriously thought about these
issues in any real way the thing about
the the religious argument that has
always appealed to me is that it seems
to me a better explanation for the life
that we live then the scientific
materialist argument and it seems to me
that the argument that there is no god
it's very difficult to square with any
sort of human meaning any sort of free
will any sort of reason all the various
principles that that so many people in
the secularist world seem to base entire
moral systems upon are based on bricks
that they've stolen from a house that
they forcibly destroyed with a wrecking
ball and this is sort of the case that I
was making to Sam Harris when he was
sitting here is that he comes up with
this entire moral system but all of his
values are based and predicated on the
notion that human beings are inherently
valuable for example where is he getting
the notion that human beings are
inherently valuable why are human beings
inherently valuable if you say reason
well why is reason inherently more
valuable then non reason considering is
just I guess an evolutionarily
beneficial biological function it's it's
sort of a neuronal or that that works
the best it's it none of that makes a
lot of sense to me well what's your
what's your chief attack on sort of the
atheistic philosophies you do
utilitarian one that it just doesn't
work or is it that you think that
there's a fundamental logic to to
atheism itself is there a probably still
man atheism for me if you you're gonna
make the the best argument you can for
the Atheist perspective what does that
look like yeah well I can answer those
two questions in tandem you know the
question that you know how would I steal
man atheism right but ultimate also
question what's wrong with it because
they're actually related in a way I want
to explain what I would do if I were to
try to make the best case for atheism
that I could would be to push as far as
I could this brute fact idea that I
rejected earlier right because I think
that's ultimately you're committed to if
you really are a rationalist deep down
in other words if you think that the
world is ultimately intelligible that
the human mind can make sense of it you
mind can penetrate its nature right you
have a very ambitious and optimistic
view of human reason and you push that
through consistent you're gonna be a
theist I mean it's no accident that the
archer rationalist in the history of
philosophy me people who really push
through this idea that the world is
ultimately intelligible we can make
sense of it they all they were all
theists they all believed in God Leibniz
Descartes people like that right even
Spinoza though his conception of God is
an eccentric one he's not an atheist
he's a pantheist but that's very
different from from atheism so I would
say that if you're gonna avoid theism
you really have to take a view that the
power of human reason is extremely
limited you have to take a very
pessimistic view of human reason and you
see that kind of view in Nietzsche you
see that kind of view in in David Hume
you see that even in some of his moods
in Bertrand Russell though in others of
his moods he's more optimistic but I
think that's the more consistent view
that you're gonna have to take which
you're not gonna have is this kind of
rosy if we just got rid of religion
everything will be wonderful kind of
idea that you get in someone like
Richard Dawkins so I would say that if
you're gonna steal man atheism you're
gonna have to swallow the consequence of
accepting that the world is ultimately
not intelligible you're probably going
to have to be less of a science booster
than you are because science really
rests on the idea that we can make sense
of the world so if the world ultimately
is
intelligible if it ultimately is brute
fact you're gonna have to have a much
more modest idea of what science can
accomplish once again David Hume
Friedrich Nietzsche had exactly that
kind of modesty about the possibility of
scientific knowledge so that's what I
would say is you know if I wanted to be
if I wanted to sort of give it the
Atheist advice as to where to go to make
his position as defensible as possible
and as a little open to the sort of
objections I would raise that's the
direction I would go but that brings me
to what the main problem I think with
atheism is with atheism which is that
ultimately you can't make that position
work it's ultimately a self-defeating
position if you ultimately take the view
that nature is not intelligible that we
can't make sense of the view you're
ultimately it makes sense of the world
you're ultimately undermining the power
of human reason to such an extent that
it takes down any argument you can give
for any conclusion including any
argument you can give for atheism so I
ultimately don't think atheism is a
coherent or consistent position and
that's what I think is the main problem
with it it has all kinds of practical
downsides as well but those are less
fundamental than the fact it's just
false and it's not rationally defensible
well then this is this is also you know
the the argument that Harris has made in
Reverse you he'll make the argument
essentially that well atheism may not be
tenable in terms of supporting things
like free will you have to act that way
anyway there's there's a certain level
of whistling past the graveyard that I
feel like you get from from some a
theist where yes we can change the world
if we just get rid of religion and yes
we can have rational discussions and I
just keep thinking where are you getting
the tools to do all of these things I
mean you are basically a ball of meat
wandering aimlessly through the universe
randomly firing neurons and yet I'm
supposed to believe that we can
construct entire moral systems change
our lives for the better and make
civilization a rosy wonderful place as
reading a Wilson in his in associate
biological theater theories and he gets
almost to the verge of what you're
talking about where he basically says
that everything is an outgrowth of
evolution and biology and then at the
very last instant he sort of viewers
away from him because he realizes that
the conclusion is just too depressing
and self-defeating which is that every
change that has ever occurred was bound
to happen it was not it was not willed
there's no possibility for actual change
almost ends up in a sort of human Zeno's
paradox where changes occurring all
around you but it can't actually be
occurring all around you
well I think that guys like Harris are
probably misled by the fact that they're
mistaking what they take to be their own
status as nice guys right as evidence
that it's possible to have a moral world
say even if morality is an illusion so
someone like Harris might think well I'm
a nice guy I'm not you know I wouldn't
murder and steal and kill and so forth
and some of my atheist friends are like
that right and that would be true even
if it turned out that morality is an
illusion even if it turned out that free
will is an illusion therefore you could
have a white you could have a sighting
which belief that morality and freewill
or illusions was widespread that doesn't
follow it's very naive to think that
what might be true of the individual
person here or there could be true at
the level of mass society where
everybody just took it for granted that
freewill was an illusion morality was an
illusion but a useful illusion right
there would be an it would be
irresistible to cut corners where you
could get away with it because it's just
an illusion after all anyway right so I
think there's a kind of sociological
naivete behind this idea that you know
morality could still work even if it
were even if we all just agree that was
false and agreed not to talk about it
very much okay so get to more on that in
just one second first let's talk about
your hiring practices your business so
hiring used to be hard multiple job
sites stacks of resumes confusing review
process but today hiring can be easy
only have to go to one place to get it
done sip recruiter comm slash been guest
because I have a guest
zip recruiter sends your jobs to over
100 of the web's leading job boards but
they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruiter is so effective that 80%
of employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate through the site
within the first day with results like
that it's no wonder zip recruiter is the
highest rated hiring site in America and
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash Ben
gasps that's be Eng u est as zip
recruiter comm slash been guest again
zip recruiter comm slash Ben gasps zip
recruiters the best way to hire Ouisa
today Lee Weyer there's a reason we use
it here it's because if our employees
screw up we need to find new employees
who are better and that's why zip
recruiter is awesome go check it out
right now
recruiter comm / Ben guess to try it out
the smartest way to hire zip recruiter
okay so let's talk about the
construction of morality so now we've
talked about the the construction of
arguments that support the existence of
God but we're atheists usually goes once
you've started arguing that the
Spaghetti Monster argument isn't
particularly productive for them or
fulfilling for them and you actually
have some pretty good arguments for
God's existence they immediately leap to
okay there's a bunch of stuff in the
Bible I don't like right there's a bunch
of verses in the Bible I don't like is
it possible or necessary or useful to
construct a morality simply on the basis
of God exists does that really help you
construct some sort of objective
morality that can be useful i acquiesce
in the belief that it's more useful than
atheism scientific materialism can't
really generate and in facts don't have
anything to say about actual values but
there's a serious fact value distinction
but let's say that we now all
acknowledge that God exists can you
actually generate a moral system that
works off of that or do you still need
some sort of religious tradition well I
think it's neither and what I mean by
that is this that atheists often suppose
that the traditional you know defenders
of God's existence at Thomas Aquinas or
an Aristotle or alignments or to have
you are committed to the idea that
religion and morality are related in the
following way that morality is
essentially a matter of God arbitrarily
giving certain commands right don't
murder don't steal and that if you ask
well why because I said so
right that God just arbitrarily
stipulates that certain things are wrong
and that if you believe that there's a
link between religion or morality that
must be what you mean that's not what
thinkers like that meant by that if you
look at something like Thomas Aquinas
and here his ideas are as they so often
are grounded in Aristotle morality is
fundamentally grounded in human nature
this is the idea of morality as natural
law now there is a link to religion but
it's not as direct as as atheists often
suppose it's more indirect the idea is
that what's good or bad for something is
to turn by its nature that things by
their nature have certain tasks they
have to perform they have certain ends
or goals they have to fulfill in order
to flourish the kinds of things that
they are so forget about human beings
for the moment right just think of
something like to use some stock
examples ideas a tree or an animal like
a squirrel or a bird or something right
a tree given
it's nature as a tree if it's gonna
flourish has to realize certain ends or
goals it's got to sync roots into the
ground to give it stability and to take
in water it's got to grow bark to
protect it from the elements and insects
if it doesn't realize those goals you
might say it's not going to be a very
good tree it's not gonna flourish is a
good specimen of a tree same thing with
the squirrel it's gonna flourish as that
kind of animal as a squirrel it's got to
gather its nuts and acorns for the
winter it's got a scamper about and
evade predators and so forth if it fails
to do those things it's not going to
flourish as a squirrel now human beings
are like that too we have certain ends
we have to pursue certain goals we have
to realize or reach if we're gonna
flourish as the kinds of things that we
are for example human beings are
rational animals unlike other animals
we've got intellects we've got
rationality and free choice so we need
to learn things about the world we need
to study we need to investigate there
what we need to do things like science
and philosophy or we're not gonna
flourish the kinds of things that we are
now just as it's a matter of objective
fact that a tree that fails to sink
roots is a bad tree in the sense of a
bad specimen a defective specimen of a
tree and the squirrel that fails to
gather acorns and nuts and so forth is a
defective or bad specimen of being a
squirrel so to a human being that fails
to realize the ends or goals that are
built into our nature is a bad specimen
of a human being now you'll notice that
I didn't make any reference to God there
right I just made reference to human
nature what I did at least presuppose
however is that there really is in the
nature of things objectively it's
something that's that's there we
discovered we don't just make it up
there really are purposes or goals in
nature that's something that modern
atheism rejects alongside its rejection
of God the idea that there really is any
purpose built into the very nature of
the physical world what Aristotle called
final causality final cause or end or
goal or purpose right and they often
reject this idea on the basis of modern
science they say well modern science has
shown there are no purposes in nature
there are no final causes what I would
say is that modern science has shown no
such thing
modern science simply brackets that
question oh if it doesn't look for final
causes it looks for it looks for things
you can put in the language of
mathematics and you can't put purpose in
the language of mathematics so for
scientific purposes physics just ignores
that that's very different from show
it doesn't exist but once you have that
in place now I would argue that you
could show that there must really be
such things in nature as final cause
then you got the foundation for a system
of ethics that doesn't have to make
reference to Scripture and it doesn't
have to make reference to some arbitrary
divine command but just a human nature
now Scripture and divine commands are
related all that they get worked in to
that as well in a whole system of
religious ethics but that would be the
starting point or foundation so what's
the argument for final clauses what's
the argue and the scientific argument
for final causes because it seems pretty
evidence into the same harris's of the
world that as you say there are no final
clauses there you uproot facts that's
that the world is made up of them and
then our minds kind of place those
causes on the brute facts in order to
make sense of the world what's the best
argument in favor of the idea that you
don't discover the normative from the
from the descriptive basically what I
would say is there there's several
arguments some of them more technical
than others that you give for the
existence of final cause or purpose in
the natural world but probably the the
one that's easiest to understand for the
non philosophers the idea that if there
is no final cause or purpose built into
nature at all right if the whole idea
final cause or purpose is an illusion
then that means that human reason itself
has no final cause or purpose it doesn't
aim or point at anything but if that's
the case then the human mind the human
intellect doesn't aim or point at truth
as its final cause or goal either if
that's the case if the human intellect
if the human mind if human reason isn't
really for anything it doesn't have the
attainment of truth as its final cause
or goal because there are no final
causes or goals that means there really
is no such thing objectively as a
difference between good reasoning and
bad reasoning between good arguments and
logical fallacies it's all ultimately
just a matter of power of imposing your
will on others now I would say you can't
really make coherent sense of that even
to give an argument for that claim you
need to presuppose that the arguments a
good one not an argument commits a
fallacy even someone wants to deny that
there's a difference between good and
bad arguments it's gonna have to give
you an argument for that and therefore
presuppose that there is such a
difference but if you could you
theoretically make an evolutionary claim
to counter that so you say you're right
there's no such thing as good reason or
batteries and there's just reason that
works right and then and I've heard
Harris actually make this argument
he made on stage with me he basically
said that yes I love raisin bed that's
because reason is useful right it's not
because reason searches for truth even
though he does believe in objective
truth which I've never really understood
he says that reason basically allows you
to convince the most numbers people cuz
your brain basically is like a lock when
you come up with the reasonable
combination somebody's brain basically
unlocks and now they're on your side
could you make the argument in favor of
good reason not on the basis of its
aiming at truth and then and then truth
is the objective but convincing people
is the objective because then you are
evolutionarily a winner basically yeah
well there are two problems with that
depending on how someone like Harris
would cash out that claim right if he
wants to say that natural selection
could explain why the human mind really
aims at truth I would say it doesn't it
can't explain that because all natural
selection favors is fitness right being
well adapt to the environment passing
your genes on to the next generation and
there's no necessary link between that
and truth it could turn out for all we
know that sometimes it's more adaptive
to believe falsehoods if that's the case
the natural selection wouldn't favor
intellects or minds that attain truth
we're just favored intellect our minds
that allow you to have greater unless
you make that argument the context of
religion right they say the religion is
a Spano and and just because your
religion is really popular doesn't mean
that it's true is just that it's a
byproduct of minds that are
evolutionarily fit that's right so
they're going to say that about religion
they say yeah religion a tendency toward
religion is hardwired into us because it
has certain fitness characteristics but
it's not true well there's no reason not
to extend that to human reason in
general
in which case you'd better solve
undermining position so if he's going to
say that natural selection explains our
capacity for truth I would say that
natural selection by the very nature
could do no such thing
it's just not in that business of
explaining that kind of thing if instead
he says oh no no I'm not trying to
explain how natural selection favors
truth I'm just trying to say that net
that human reason is it must be a useful
instrument because I survive the process
of natural selection okay if he says
that then he's back with the the
skeptical position that I already
criticized a few moments ago which is
that he's basically conceding that there
is objectively no difference between
good and bad reasoning there's just
reasoning that wins the mob over and
reasoning that doesn't but in that case
he couldn't present his own position as
the more true or rational position he's
gonna be and he's gonna end up with a
self undermining
self-defeating position okay so what
happens to reason in to to connect it
with any sort of moral principle let's
say we assume that the Aristotelian
version of the nature of man is right
that basically our nature is to be a
rational animal and that in order for us
to pursue our Tilos we have to we have
to be as rational as possible or at
least pursue rational ends how does that
connect to morality because one of the
things that we saw between the 19th and
20th centuries is a lot of people who
thought that they were being as purely
rational as possible who then proceeded
to kill tens of millions of human beings
so how do we get from know so we've
gotten from God to reason as an end I
guess and so how do we get from there to
anything that looks like a moral system
yeah well I mean what you see in the
kind of systems of thought that you're
describing there is a kind of incoherent
or bastardized version of reason I mean
on the one hand they in the name of
rationality they favor things like a
centrally planned economy and so I
assume your so your referent communism
and Maoism as Stalin ISM as
manifestations of that and so forth but
my argument is that if you follow
through consistently the idea that
reason really has its end truth the
attainment of truth you're gonna be
committed to final cause the purpose is
built into nature before you know you're
gonna have to accept a natural law
conception of morality which tells us
that the the things that are good or bad
for us as human beings are there in the
nature of things they're there for us to
discover and not to invent right and
that means that there are absolute
limits on the power of any state any
government say to manipulate human
beings according to its whims and so
forth it's gonna have to submit itself
to the dictates of the natural law and
therefore it's not going to be a
totalitarian state so you can't
consistently in the name of Reason end
up with a kind of totalitarian or status
system I think there's a there's a
contradiction lurking in that very idea
when you want packet and that that may
be a contradiction between Plato and
Aristotle because in Plato's Republic he
basically argues that theoretically you
could have the rule of reason from the
top that looks essentially like a
tyranny and Aristotle is a lot more
divided on the question of the power of
government it seems yeah that raises
questions about how to interpret Plato
is play to a serious about and so forth
but even Plato though I you know I mean
one of the things that's interesting
about Plato's Republic which I think
often don't don't pay careful attention
to is that what seems like a
totalitarian society into the sort of
sort of rigidly regimented society right
that applies primarily to the Guardian
class not to the mass of human beings
right it's only the small elites that
has to live this very austere military
sort of totalitarian lifestyle and they
have to do it in Plato precisely that is
not attractive right for Plato you have
to guarantee that being a ruler in his
utopian society is as unattractive as
possible to anybody but those with the
purest motives modern totalitarian
states were anything but like that right
they weren't like that at all having
said that Aristotle is definitely more
down to earth
thinker than Plato even Plato later and
his career moved away from this rather
sort of strange utopian model that he
presented in the in the Republic but
Aristotle is much more the philosopher
of of common sense so the argument that
I've made and making an upcoming book on
some of these topics is that with all
the glorification of Aristotle all the
glorification of human reason that there
still doesn't need to be an admixture
with essentially one revealed truth not
necessarily every everything that's in
the Bible is necessary to supply the
basis for natural rights as we
understand them but you do need
basically one verse and that is that man
is made in the image of God that you do
need the idea that every human being is
imbued with a certain level of Rights by
nature of their very existence does that
do you think that exists in the ancients
in the same way because it seems yeah
obviously Plato and Aristotle were okay
with slavery there's a pretty solid
regimentation of human beings into
people who are fitted for one class
versus people who are fitted for another
class do you think that we need that
sort of biblical admixture do you think
that it could have been over time
evolved from the Greek position purely I
think we do need that biblical admixture
I don't think it could have evolved you
do see an Aristotle something like an
echo of the idea that human beings are
made in God's image in this sense that
he thinks that rationality which every
human being has some degree of is the
divine spark in us that's what's most
what is most godlike but beyond that it
doesn't have in Aristotle a lot of
practical application to the life of the
average person this idea that absolutely
every human being has a
certain dignity and an eternal destiny
and so forth and especially loved by God
right you certainly don't have that in
Aristotle and Aristotle the unmoved
mover God contemplates one thing himself
because nothing else is worth
contemplating right but you don't see
that idea in the philosophers influenced
by the Bible by Maimonides in Judaism by
Thomas Aquinas in Christianity you have
this idea of the the dignity of the
individual human being and the eternal
destiny of the individual human being
that really is something that biblical
religion introduces and I think it is
absolutely necessary that's its origin I
mean even even liberalism which still
uses the language of human dignity it
really is a kind of heresy you might say
a biblical religion what I mean by that
is something that grew out of biblical
religion and then chucked away its
origins and supposes that you can
maintain this idea of human dignity
without the the biblical source of it
and I would say ultimately that's
incoherent so now we're in the now we're
in the realm of more traditional
religion as a lot of religious people
feel the talk about immortality and the
value of each human being made in the
image of God and all the rest of this
what do you think is the best proof for
a soul this is one I've personally had a
tough time with because the truth is
that the Old Testament isn't big it's
big on the idea that there's a soul
because it says right in Genesis that
God breathes breath into Adam and all of
this but there's nothing in the Old
Testament that explicitly references the
idea of an afterlife for example so
what's the rational case I know that
you've discussed this before what's the
rational case for the idea of a soul
what exactly is a soul what is there is
there a rational case for an afterlife
or is that just something that we've
made up to comfort ourselves I would say
that the the the arguments for
immortality that I think are the most
impressive and actually these are
arguments that for whatever reason end
up being a little bit philosophically
more technical than the arguments for
God's existence or at least it's a
little bit harder to state them in a
non-technical way but the arguments that
I have in mind focus on what's unique
about the human intellect the human
power of rationality which other animals
don't have other animals are clever in
certain ways they can you know they can
they can hunt prey and they can solve
certain problems you know but what they
don't have is the idea to grasp
ABB's
tract ideas abstract concepts the sort
of thing that we express in language in
distinctively human language that's the
difference in human beings that entails
when you unpack it and this is something
that Plato argues Aristotle argues this
as well Thomas Aquinas argues this as
well when you impact this idea of the
human intellect you'll find that it's a
power in us it's a capacity that's not
material that is to say it's not
entirely grounded in bodily processes
not even neural processes processes in
the brain now they don't deny Aristotle
and Aquinas certainly would not deny
that brain activity is part of what's
going on when we think but they would
argue that can't be the whole story that
which you can't with what matter by
itself will not give you is the kind of
meaning that you have in a human thought
or in a sentence that you write in a
human language it expresses a human
thought that's an a non physical or
immaterial aspect to human nature now
because if that's the case then because
it's the case when humans die what
happens is we lose our bodily capacities
we walk and we talk those things depend
on bodily organs like arms and legs and
mouths and so forth we digest food that
depends on a bodily capacity bodily
organs like having a stomach we see in
here that depends on bodily organs like
eyes and ears those things are gone but
at least part of what we do even when
we're alive namely thinking in the
abstract thought of the sort that even
the the the least intellectual human
being is capable of can still grasp
abstract ideas that's something that for
Plato and for Aristotle and for Thomas
Aquinas is not a physical or material
power of human nature is something we do
even more alive that is immaterial
and so that aspect of us does not go out
go out of existence at death it carries
on beyond death and that's the
foundation in these writers for an
argument for the immortality of the
human soul that there's an aspect of
human nature
what's highest in us namely our capacity
for thought that survives the death of
the body so even without a brain even
without any any ability to function in
the physical world there is something
else but we can't quite define what
exactly that is that is this arise
afterward I don't want to say
we can't define I think we can define I
think I would say I mean the short
answer would be that it's the human
intellect the human mind that survives
the death of the body and that cannot be
entirely explained in terms of or reduce
to brain activity here you start to see
a divergence between thinkers in the
tradition I'm talking about
so for a rider like play-doh or Rene
Descartes father of modern philosophy
for them not only is the human mind the
highest part of our nature but that's
really definitive of us what we are
essentially is thinking things and the
body's just a is just a vehicle we
temporarily walk around it or it's even
a prison for for Plato so death is a
kind of liberation but for Aristotle and
for Thomas Aquinas that's not the case
for them even though we're not entirely
bodily there's an aspect of us namely
our intellects our minds that's that's
not reducible to bodily behavior
nevertheless our bodily activity is
still part of us and so death is not a
liberation death is really you know what
I like to call it as in Aquinas is
thinking death is like a full-body
amputation that's something that's bad
you want your body back that's why you
need in the thinking of Thomas Aquinas
need a resurrection from the dead now
that's where for Aquinas philosophy has
to give way to theology he thinks
philosophy can demonstrate that the
human soul is immortal but what it can't
demonstrate is that we could ever get
our bodies back that would require
special divine intervention and that's
even a possibility requires divine
revelation to know about it requires
biblical revelation to know about
that's where theology picks up the baton
from theology money from philosophy when
it comes to the in selected the mind
that survives death does that have any
it doesn't have any impacts whether
we're talking about somebody who is a
baby who has an undeveloped brain or
doesn't matter if your brain is
developed like the way we normally think
of intellect in mind is obviously imbued
with these physical characteristics but
you know to take an abortion example if
somebody would argue well the intellect
isn't developed to feed us and it's just
it's it it's basically got very little
brain function is it a problem to kill
that thing because is it really even
living if it doesn't have this immoral
soul that we've now posited what gives a
non thinking person or human this
capacity of immortality that makes them
valuable in this perspective well what
what followers of Aquinas argue is it in
the case of a baby or a fetus or what
have you it's not that they don't have
intellects or souls they do have them
but what they don't have is an Alexis or
souls that are developed because for
Aquinas though the intellect is not a
physical thing it's an incorporeal or
non material aspect of human nature
nevertheless the five senses and brain
activity are its normal mode for
acquiring information it's like its it
would be otherwise like a computer
that's kicked off the internet because
the modem is not working right so the
the the fetus or the small child is the
baby has just been born it's basically
like a computer that's just been
connected the internet it's downloading
information but not a whole lot has been
downloaded onto it yet but nevertheless
just as a computer still exists whether
or not it's connected to the Internet
whether or not it's got a modem in the
same way the unborn child the fetus or
the newborn infant still has a soul
still has an intellect but it's one that
has not yet developed so it's not that
the fetus or the child is potentially a
human being or potentially something
with the soul or an intellect no it's
something that actually has an intellect
actually has a soul but intellects and
souls that have not yet attained their
potentials that's a different idea okay
so with all of the set I mean we've
gotten pretty obtrusive tried to bring
it down to the point where I can
understand it at least and with all that
said one of the things that's that's
pretty obvious is that we as a
civilization have sort of lost our way
in terms of these fundamental Western
values because all of this is the basis
for a Western civilization that actually
believes in human rights and individual
rights and women's rights and all the
things that we actually care about in
the West can this stuff be relocated is
it have we lost it and is it have we
lost it because we lost the
philosophical roots or because we were
seduced by you know the excesses of
materialism around us what do you think
it what do you think happened to Western
civilization because all these ideas are
not new to you they're obviously not new
to me that I got them from you many of
them and then who got them from people
who are about to older so what exactly
happened that it feels like very few
people in the West are you even familiar
with these ideas
I wouldn't reduce it to one factor but
as I put it in my book the last
superstition which came out about ten
yes it's tennant 10th anniversary now
that book
now for about ten years at least on the
philosophical side of things the
intellectual or academic side of things
I think the greatest mistake I think the
way I put it in the book was that the
single greatest mistake ever made in the
history of Western thought was
abandoning Aristotle and more generally
classical philosophy Plato Aristotle
Augustine Thomas Aquinas
Maimonides the whole medieval and
ancient tradition on which Western
civilization been founded that's its
intellectual foundation and that that
provides the foundation for these
arguments for the immortality of the
soul and the existence of God and the
natural law conception of morality that
we've been talking about and we're kind
of a common coin for pagans and Jews and
Christians for so long that was
abandoned about four hundred years ago
with the rise of modern philosophy and
we've been seeing for the last three and
fifty four hundred years is basically
the gradual unspooling of the
implications of that the working out of
the implications of that as that idea
that all that stuff is old hat we need
to chuck it out and get rid of it took
root in the intelligencia and started to
permeate the thinking of academics and
intellectuals and writers and so on and
so forth that I think is the at least
the intellectual or theoretical side of
the modern problem that now there are
all kinds of other factors as well but I
would say that that at least that the
the level of philosophy that is the main
problem ok so I have one more question
for you and it's the biggest one which
is what is the purpose of life and how
do we attain it so we'll do that in one
second but first if you actually want to
hear professor phasors answer you have
to be a daily wire subscriber subscribe
head over to daily wire comm and then
click Subscribe which helps us bring you
the show great singer thank you
[Music]
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Hiromi no hair and makeup
is by Jess wah all Vera and title
graphics by Cynthia and Gullu Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2018
[Music]